the end objective here is to escape not
get enough supplies to just be
comfortable
hello everybody my name is Markiplier
and welcome back to amnesia the Dark
Descent
that was actually a mistake I didn't
mean to say that Amnesia the bunker
I feel like that was pulled up from
somewhere deep deep in my memories
um but I don't need it right now because
I need to survive
and I'm going to survive because I need
to go put this dynamite over there
before I do anything else
I'm not gonna turn on the lights for
that because I'm a big strong man and
there's a light over here which is
helpful so if I put the dynamite let's
say for example here
[Music]
oh yeah
wait one
I thought you were gonna lay it sideways
in there you know take up the whole
space Oh okay there we go I thought you
were saying that I needed to get more
than that and I would have been very
upset because it was it was bad enough
trying to get enough for just that all
right so now that we did that won't lock
myself out
I know that they're probably going to
remove my sense of safety with that but
for now I feel very very very safe
so the question is actually the question
is what what do I need to do to get down
to maintenance because I don't remember
even being there I should probably take
a look and man I've been doing bad about
getting the um maps to these areas
because I haven't been blowing the doors
off of them and again I know that's
probably not the correct strategy but
it's the only strategy I have at the
moment
besides you know screaming for my life
begging for mercy
trying to offer favors to the monster to
let me survive I don't actually need any
more gas so what we're gonna do is we're
gonna do a little bit of exploration
while I find out what
[Music]
ah a Molotov
I don't know
I feel like one of these should be able
to fill two of those but
no
no no no
[Music]
no no no no
no I don't need it
damn it
no butt of stick
you can craft in this game I just
realized this in a game where I've been
crafting for a while you can craft
so basically a torch is like a flare
how long does that last probably not
very long but it's something I like
something so the other something is if I
always keep my fuel full I don't need to
be worried about how much time I have
right because I always know that I'll be
back before it's dark
right
well at all
be dumb
that would be I just want to go see what
the deal is with the maintenance over
there I feel like I should be able to
make it down there check what I need to
get in there and then not worry about it
anymore and I can do that because I'm
very brave and extremely strong so I'm
gonna do exactly that let's just see
what's up there
let's just take a gander I think it was
over here to the right
quick John
just a quick little
Jean
right right
okay
um
oh oh
sh oh oh oh oh oh [__]
oh I screwed up
oh
holy [__]
oh my God
[Music]
foreign
I don't think I'm going to go out in the
darkness anymore I'm gonna go get
okay here we go
that was awful and I know I'm not safe
I know I'm not safe just because the
lights are on but I feel a lot safer and
that's
uh that's you know that's half the
battle right there
okay so what's the deal with this yep
okay good
no no no ah
so I definitely need some kind of bolt
cutters and I need to prep my hidey hole
a little better this is our fourth
formal request for a resupply of wine
The Cellar is running low I fear the
reaction among the men and my fellow
officers if we're forced to implement
harsher rationing I'm already feeling
complaints on a daily basis this Army
runs on morale and Morel Rin runs online
requested sand crate so far we've
received
okay so I need to be able to get in
there and I definitely can't blow that
open and we got rats over there which is
a problem
but I should just be able to run past
them
man you rats oh no they oh they bit me
right in the undercarriage oh [__]
oh God
oh [__]
I thought there would be a door or
something rats keep out how many
oh they're all dead
[Music]
okay
ow
also ow
requires a lighter
how do I get a lighter
was I supposed to be able to get that
stop being so squonky wow whoa okay
didn't think I'd be dropping this but
wow
drop
and a Granada which is good because I
can use that to blow up in the door
which I'm sure is the absolute best use
of that oh I need that actually
I need to make a
you need to make it this I need to make
uh this and I need to do a this and I
need to be healthy again
not so loud there buddy boo okay
so running past the rats was
why must you be terrible
okay
I don't know and I don't want to know
but I think it just slurped its way back
into the vents where the holes in the
walls
and I know this said rats keep out but I
I it didn't
seem that bad
oh frick me
oh frick okay
oh
[Music]
what is that is that a box of blood oh
I don't like it in here hello
okay that's good
okay I got a picture
yeah I just discovered how to do this
this isn't a secret this is just so
happens that I had this on my own you
know oh wow there's a lot of them in
here oh boy okay yeah but I promise you
in Christian burial but you must
understand the rats would not stop
coming they swarmed your body their
teeth their claws they wouldn't stop I
did what our ancestors did when faced
with unclean things burnt them and I
burned what was left of you to stop them
coming again and if he baited Devin
please forgive me I remain down here in
hell with that demon it will come for me
again soon I know it I'm gonna do as you
suggested before you die to make for the
pillbox please if you're up there watch
over for me
uh
listen uh I don't I don't know if you
that uh
I just I don't know
okay so I'm gonna mix one of these hold
on to it I'm keeping the grenade I'm
getting the fuel
um technically speaking I probably
should grab the this but I can always
come back for it because it seems like
there's just a ton of really nice things
going on up here what is that shotgun
shells oh that's cool only I had a
shotgun oh
okay
so I'm gonna make it back now I I've
done ex I'm done exploring
I don't want to be any I don't want to
be anywhere any longer than I need to
I'm just going for it screw this place
screw these things screw the rats which
are probably still there oh
can be swung to scare off small
Predators but I don't have a lighter
all right here we go again okay well
that really that sucked that sucks that
sucks big
Frick where am I oh
it's gonna smell my blood
it's gonna smell all of my blood oh
okay we're just gonna pretend like that
didn't happen I'm gonna go turn this off
and that was a really uh if unless my
goal was just fuel which I guess I did
get
boy that was a waste of time
oh but we're back up to full baby
hell yeah I think you do get some kind
of a bonus if you fill it up just it's
close to one it probably rounds up for
your benefit
but that's good I got that I got grenade
and I got bullets I can't use that yet
because I don't have a lighter and I
need to use that because I'm ouchied
okay well this is incredibly stressful
but we're making it I think so I don't
know why I did that I don't know why I
decided to go over there but whatever I
don't need to go there I need to go to
oh [__] I do need to go there isn't that
where the Roman tunnels were weren't
they in maintenance oh frick okay
whatever we got a new code and I'm
assuming that it goes to the locker so
we might as well grab that because we're
right here okay
okay
what are we looking for like Clement
clementor girod
okay two six one seven got it
what do we have I don't know what that
was but I got it going leaving I'm out
I'm Audi oh my god oh
foreign
[Music]
ER
oh frick and I wonder how many sticks
I've I've just like left aside I bet
there's been so many that I just I
haven't seen so I haven't picked them up
oh man okay we're home man I don't know
if I should be celebrating as much as I
am but I feel like I should be
celebrating as much as I am because wow
I am great could I even have this in my
storage I don't even know if that should
be there I feel like it could
technically just sitting over here maybe
in
another pile or something on this thing
I don't know I'm just gonna drop them
okay yes yeah it's fine okay um lighter
let's see what you do
what do you do lighter
you unlimited lighter
how much use do I have of this
something I bet it's oh it's got to be
limited I shouldn't rely on it that's
for sure and I'm Gonna Keep An Empty
Bottle on me just for distraction
purposes I'm actually gonna do that
because well I don't want to be calling
my pants down again I think the Roman
tunnels are in maintenance it says
something else is in Arsenal but I got
Dynamite I thought unless there's like
something else in my journal that says
that what I need but I don't know Ranch
and maintenance
that's what I need I need the wrench
well that means I gotta go back down
there but at least I have an objective
to go back down there well there's a lot
of stuff to hold in my inventory I'm
gonna lose the bottle
and I'm gonna turn on the power and I'm
gonna try to just get by with the
lighter to see what it can do but I
wonder if it has a limited amount of use
oh that's nothing oh that that ain't
nothing that that just makes me feel a
little better about myself this is I'm
going to
Molotov would be the perfect thing to
deal with them
yeah I'm wasting power of course but
this is this would be the this would be
the thing right so I take this
and then I take this and then I take
this and I've created a petrol bomb and
I can get another petrol bomb when I'm
over there so I'm gonna make that that
I'm gonna get this out and I'm gonna
and then I'm gonna burn those rats out
of existence
freak
oh my God
and then there's another petrol bomb in
the in the bottom
oh
good thing I aimed I whatever
oh [__]
oh
is there just fuel sitting there well I
guess I I don't know if I could I I
would still have to throw something that
flammable but all right well I need to
know can I disarm that now
okay you're still going man my fuel is
just burning much like this fire boy you
burn a lot it'd be good for keeping the
the creature away that's for sure
okay let's go
okay
so I've been in here ish no I haven't
have I have you noticed how the rats
have changed down here ever since they
opened up those tunnels I swear the rats
have gotten uglier like they're
disfigured or something and they're
definitely more aggressive
no you're crazy yes
foreign
that's nice okay fuel on bodies yeah
uh-huh and then rats ooh that's a lot of
rats yep I know it's a problem whoa
what the hell
oh
map
cool that's a lot of fuel
that's that's a lot of fuel why so much
fuel
I have so many of these I don't even
need that many all right because I'm
going back and running some fuel back
geez that's like way more fuel here than
I thought I was I was rationing at first
and I know I probably should keep around
I don't care
so I don't have to keep jumping over it
and I know I probably should keep
rationing but uh honestly this is
sick
what whoa
hi
whoa the rat the meat oh the me that
yeah okay don't leave don't even think
about it
oh God you're trapped oh oh frick oh
frick get away
oh yeah you gotta get out I guess okay
go get out of here
you go
oh
God I'm wasting fuel God damn it stupid
rat whatever I how much fuel I got uh
damn it
oh I don't know uh man I'm not doing
anything right okay got this here got
the fuel there man I've got so much fuel
I guess I could bring the torch but I
mean what I really need it yeah I don't
know I just have a lot of fuel I never
thought that I would have this situation
but I can fill one more in here
I don't quite get any bonus out of it
but I get something you know
it is full let's just get back in those
stones we we have to get what we need we
have to get the wrench because the Ranch
opens up a lot of doors and means that
we're gonna be able to get other things
that are important and I don't need to
constantly be doing these Supply runs
when I don't even have the things that I
really need the end objective here is to
escape not get enough supplies to just
be comfortable
oh my God oh my God
oh my God go get out of here
don't
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah you better oh
[__] I gotta go oh God I gotta okay I'm
I'm way uncomfortable
I'm very uncomfortable I'm extremely
uncomfortable
I'm so uncomfortable I shouldn't be
running everywhere why would I why would
I be doing any of that I I don't know
okay
um no more running
this game gets you
okay
oh
what did I do oh oh god oh no oh
no
oh
no oh I'm bleeding so bad he's gonna
find me oh no oh oh that guy knew I knew
that there was one in here oh no
okay
this game's a little unforgiving at
times
but hey at the very least
you know
don't just be willy-nilly
letting that flop out
it's pretty extreme
damn it oh rats
okay
where did I go that I just got blowed up
oh God
I just need to keep an eye out for
freaking traps apparently
why constantly with you [__]
I guess I could throw another one of
these that's what it's here for
wait
but
what can I have that back
what what
the what what why did that happen
to light it
oh there's so many rats
Workshop maybe that's where that damn
thing is
oh boy
oh rats
oh well that's dim
great empty good that's what I need
oh God is would there ever be a point of
blockading the holes I don't know if
that would work but maybe it would hi
okay damn it what the [__] [__]
oh I don't know
I don't know oh
well that's too small for
I don't even know maybe I'll block that
one
take this gas
perfect this is going so good
just turn this on
great
well you enjoy the cheese I guess it's
an explodey Barrel there not that I
I guess I could push a barrel down there
and blow it up but then I'd have to deal
with the noise
this is still locked that's
oh wait this is where I went down and
got blowed up
ah
okay
oh hi
how can I open you oh that's how well
let me see where I can run an ah that is
convenient
all right let's do it
it might not have been the best idea to
do that because it seemed like it was
leaving me alone it really did seem like
it wasn't actually being active around
here which is very nice of it and kind
of an enjoyable experience for a while
but oh well still gotta progress still
gotta do things
do you mean I'm not safe
there
what am I doing with my life how can I
be so terrible
at everything
oh
ah FDA
FDA
on FDA to you too
oh the question is oh it definitely is
not okay so that's still there all right
good to know yeah that thing didn't even
come out when I blew that up how did
that grenade not blow off that thing
there
I don't know
so what I'm gonna do is I'm gonna run
past that grenade that should be better
there we go
don't willy-nilly that
oh [__]
did it not
really
really okay
oh and I still have these which means
that I can screw up again and not
actually put it in the right spot
good
at least the medkit is there so I really
did just like hard reset me from my last
Save which is understandable you know I
did die but at the same time
kind of feel like uh
you know
not very nice
yeah yeah yeah I got you I got you oh I
got you all right
Actually I don't even know if I'm gonna
it's not like this is gonna blow
anything up I have to shoot it and I
don't want to waste bullets maybe I can
get a two for one sale
I push this in that room
and then I make noise right
come on
oh I know what will make noise
you don't like this oh [__] oh God okay
wait shoot boom what do you think of
that what
what why didn't you but you what you do
what no stop rat you can't do that what
what why did I come in what was the
point wasn't there a point to this yes
there was
or what wait I thought that was
what was the point of any of this
why why did I come in here
oh
frick this could not have gone worse
this this entire episode could not have
gone worse so I'm about to do the best
Amnesia the bunker of my life it's
because I started off with the wrong
name I know you [__] are still there
like how is this Fair
how is this fair I need that I'm going
for it screw it
ow oh well I'm already here so I might
as oh man I it's not letting me is it
you know
Lexi and fast forward
fast forward so what I'm gonna do is I'm
going to use the
Forge
wait where are you leaving
yeah
yeah get back get back get out of here
get out of there get out of here
I'll read that later there's another one
hey Fortune
whoa whoa way hey oh whoa whoa back off
wrong with you
oh really oh why are you locked God damn
it that thing had to bite me really get
out of here get out of here
is that a flare get out of here you
promised you would stay away get out of
here
so I can't carry that
uh oh it's almost dead whoa God you guys
are really unfairly relentless
oh hard and I'm bleeding aren't I God
damn it these rats get out of here
get out of there
get going
oh [__] oh no oh no that's not good
okay so what was the hold up here oh
right rat's down there right I could
have come ah man I really should have
just done this from the get-go
oh wow you know
what
anyway
um maybe we could do gas grenade
is that working you feel gassy
oh yay
no don't go back don't go back
that's right don't don't you don't wanna
whoa whoa wait whoa whoa whoa hey whoa
are you going in the gas I don't know
I'm going for it oh God this was a
terrible idea oh frick oh
oh frick oh oh oh oh my God
everything is the worst it's ever been
nothing has ever been as bad as this
right now
oh I'm so blood oh I could use a meth
kit
anyone
oh boy oh that's not good
I'll unlock oh I have to shoot it I'm
feeling a little woozy guys
just need one more Rag and I'll be fine
just one Rag and oh for even better than
a rag actually if you think about it
okay and I better probably
let's go to the chapel
oh
freak oh frick
foreign
okay
oh frick
can I just have that
ah interesting so I really don't want to
do that or else it's gonna I think it's
gonna blow up the whole facility
that thing
there's another rag
oh this is molotovs for days oh that was
empty that's why it didn't light because
it was empty oh makes perfect sense now
okay so what I'm gonna do is I'm gonna
just shoot this lock if I have another
bullet left
which I actually don't know if I do
I do I have many
oh [__] this is a bad timing law
you left
foreign
electrical disturbances oh boy don't do
that now
any more traps why is this so bloody
like this
this is very uncompy
oh
oh no
oh God
freaking Outlast in here
oh my God why
why
oh oh good
good and Eau Claire
even better
what why
why has this occurred
I've got to be running out of fuel you
know
but I got a note to read I sit down
dusk I sit now at the bedside of my dear
friend clemel the doctor has left but I
remain I feel I must record the
extraordinary twists of fate and fortune
that have led me to be here breathing
alive strong and well while I realize
unconscious fighting for his life
starts days ago on a night Patrol I fell
into some kind of pit
I was injured and able to move
unable to escape
by All rights it should have been my
tomb
I cried for help
screamed myself Force the effort left me
parched exhausted and still alone
as the next night fell as I cried What
Might Have Been My Last Cry for Help
beautiful
and then criminal's face appeared at the
top of the pit
he lowered himself to me
found a trickle of spring water there
and had me drink from it
with a strange
taste
never has water felt more nourishing
than that
administered by a dear friend's hand
I was saved
but of course that is not the last twist
Fates blade would stab into my back
11th of July 1916 night
later now I continue my Tale
carried me across no man's land
Faith struck again
a German Outpost spotted us
gunfire
explosions desperation
and as the air cleared I pulled myself
to my feet and so that Ari was wounded
blood pouring from his head his eyes
glassy he was failing
I do not know where I found the strength
to carry him but carry him I did all the
way back to our bunker
12th July 1916 morning
woke this morning and realized that a
toy I purchased for my son is gone
I promised him I'd bring him something
home from the front so I brought him a
stuffed rabbit from a local shop
a rabbit because he thinks he's so fast
it must have fallen from my back when I
fell into the crater
the thought of that stuffed rabbit lying
in that crater
rain and weather matting its fur
unloved
forgotten
totally alone
lost forever
it fills me with profound hopelessness
12th July 1916 afternoon
spoke to the doctor
he told me or re-woke in the night and
had no recollection of the events in the
crater indeed he seemed even confused as
to where he was
aside from this disturbing news I'm
feeling rather good stronger and
stronger as if the whole ordeal has
filled both my body and soul with new
purpose
um is the monster
[Music]
oh
oh oh oh oh no not now that's not what I
meant to do
thank you
what is key for pillbox ah good
oh
I've got my gun now
I really wish I wasn't in this box oh
boy okay I'm gonna shoot you if you open
this I must shoot you right in your face
I should cut it no yes
the generator is going to run out of
fuel like any second now
hello
how are you who did this to you
uh
well
this has been a lovely Excursion I want
to go
I would like to leave now
forever and never come back
I still don't have the wrench but screw
the wrench
screw it to high hell
I should get the pillbox
I don't even remember really where the
pill box was in relation to where I am
right now oh I'm running screw those
guys yeah
where was the where would the pill box
be Workshop I don't know it definitely
wasn't there because that didn't get me
to where I needed to be is it behind
this this is it behind lace probably is
but I can't get that way unless there's
a way around through that Rat's Nest
over there says the pill box is over
there but I I can't see where the hell
any oh
pill box
frick I'm gonna run out of fuel any
second now oh I didn't even bring my
watch
oh frick
where
oh freak
I see
don't do it
I know where the pillbox key is I have
it in my hand right now
oh
that's kind of nice
can I use this perfect
I had just a little bit of Health
missing and if I if I had blood leaking
that was going to lead something to me
that I didn't want that
okay oh freedom
freedom
Freedom dumb oh freedom freedom
well this is nice
oh that's not awesome
okay still at War still warring war is
still occurring
war is uh happening okay
oh don't go too high there all right why
did I come up here I don't know
because I should put on a helmet Maybe
nade is that really really what I need
at the moment um
nothing but molotovs baby
um
why did I come up here
oh man I really
wish that why did I come up here
what did I need up here
there was a circle on my map that said
to go up here I can hide under tables oh
it probably was just to get the code
from this guy
I have a lot of codes I should use them
okay yep yep my time is now
okay
man War just keeps going
you're addicted here
what is this way
storage oh really
oh
really
well that's why they gave me a grenade
use it
no no I could have blown this up
that would have made a lot of sense
right
oh God
[Music]
I don't want to choose the war over this
but you can you climb
you climb
I gotta get out of here I gotta
get out of here I just gotta get out of
here I gotta get whatever's in the
municip stores and then I just gotta get
out of here I just gotta get out of here
oh it did okay I was like did it even go
through that and it's like yeah
oh yeah I did
okay what if what that's nothing oh but
there's something behind it
no Munitions huh nothing no munis
really
you know
no munis zero munis okay
one
and one fuel that's well then now
there's a partial molotov in the munis
in the muni store
and nothing else really really worth it
horrendously worth it when I took
Tremblay I saw its face as a Torah to
him it looked right at me and I think I
think I maybe know who it who I was
maybe it knew who I was what the hell
was it yeah okay I'm out of here
I'm out of here I want I want out I want
out I want out I want out
I want to go home I want gunsies
I am done
I didn't get what I came for
but that's okay
I am done
no more
no more oh
and and the curse and the curse and the
curse okay curse is over
all right
I see the circles now I mean okay I have
everything I need but I'm all out of
time so thank you everybody so much for
watching this has been one of the most
stressful episodes I could have ever
imagined so I'm gonna hopefully forget
about this I can't drink so I can't
drink to forget but I'll do something
else like bash my face against the wall
thank you and as always I will see you
in the next video bye-bye
[Music]